the single greatest threat to the future
of cinema scenes isn't the studios or
the haters or the normal non obsessed
moviegoers it is instead a simple house
cat meet the Official nemesis of
cinemasins the sinister Wallace has
three main methods of attack that we
need to watch out for
first general cuteness this might
include chasing his own tail rolling
around making dua so we're getting stuck
somewhere adorable
if those methods are unsuccessful
Wallace moves on to his pestering
attacks they are quite lethal
lastly when all other means have failed
Wallace goes all-in with a full-scale
hostile takeover of my workspace this is
often followed by celebratory taunting
and further unnecessary cuteness if you
see Wallace out and about do not
approach this animal he will stop you
from nitpicking movies and nobody has
time for that rest assured cinemasins is
not defenseless operation taste of zone
medicine is well underway we will keep
you apprised